Now, finally, there are some
overrides that we need for
when the connection fails
called onConnectionFailed, or
the client gets disconnected
called onDisconnected.
For these, we'll just log the event,
and in the case of failure,
we'll also log the relevant error code.
And now that we've added these,
we've gotten everything that we need, so
let's run the application and
see what happens.
Awesome!
As you can see, it works.
Now take some time to
make your changes and
finish up the app on your own machine.
Maybe you could even do something simple
like making these labels a little big
bigger so they're easier to read.
Have fun playing with
the application and
seeing the kind of things
you can do with it.
Maybe visualizing latitude and
longitude in a lot more nicer way than
we've done here, by just using numbers.
You might be able to use,
like, a dial on a compass, or
something along those lines.
Well, whatever you do, have fun with
it and let's see what you can do next.